-Welcome back to "Late Night."
Facebook has come under
fire recently
for spreading misinformation
and for reportedly
triggering depression
and anxiety,
particularly among young women.
One person we haven't heard
all that much from
is Facebook's chief operating
officer, Sheryl Sandberg.
please welcome her to the show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, Seth, for giving me
the opportunity to comment,
or as we like to say
at Facebook,
the opportunity to comment.
[ Laughter ]
-So, there's been so much
negative press
surrounding Facebook.
By the way, should I be calling
it Meta?
-Oh, no. We have no expectation
that anyone will ever do that.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
So, with regards
to Facebook then,
let me begin by asking --
-Well, first, Seth,
I just want to say
that I am a woman.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And as a woman...
I am a daughter.
[ Laughter ]
And as a daughter...
I am also the mother
of a daughter, a girl.
-Okay, you know, I think
we get --
-A sister of someone's
mother's daughter.
-Uh-huh.
-The proud granddaughter
of a lady who is also a sister,
a niece, an aunt and a wife.
-Can we get back to Facebook?
-Sure, sure, but Seth...
-Mm-hmm.
-...Seth, as a woman
in the workforce...
-Uh-huh.
-...I am a female who strives
to make her sister's
mom's aunt prouder
than if it were her own
daughter's cousin's girl child.
[ Laughter ]
-So about the specific
allegations
that Facebook executives
knowingly --
-Godmothers, stepmothers
and all mothers can experience
what it means to be
a working career woman.
Along with our single sisters,
daughters, girl cousins,
nieces, aunts, brothers'
sisters, stepsisters,
half sisters, husbands' wives
and wives' wives.
ladies who lunch
but also ladies who brunch.
In other words, women.
Women.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Great. Great.
And Seth, don't forget
to share this clip
on Facebook and Instagram.
And, uh...
lean in, will you?
-Okay.
Sheryl Sandberg, everyone.